the circle x squared plus y squared
minus 8x is equal to zero and the
hyperbola x squared over nine minus y
squared over four is equal to one
intersect at the points a and b
in problem 46 they tell us equation or
they want us to find equation of the
circle with a b
as its diameter so let's think about
let's visualize the circle and the
hyperbola the equation of the circle x
squared plus y squared minus 8x let me
write it this way
this can be rewritten as x squared minus
8x
plus y squared is equal to 0. you can
add 16 to both sides and i'm doing that
to complete the square for the x terms
so plus 16
plus 16
this over here becomes x minus 4 squared
x minus 4 squared
plus y squared is equal to 16 and so the
circle is going to look something like
this
that's my x-axis
that's my y-axis its center is at 4 0 so
1 2 3 4 4 0 and its radius is 4 its
radius squared is 16. so its radius is
4. so let me go 1
2 3 4 1 2 3 4 let me go up 4 1 2 3 4.
so all of these points that point that
point that point and that point are all
going to be on the circle let me draw
that a little bit neater
that point that point and that point are
all going to be on our circle so my
circle is going to look
something
something like this it's not drawn as
neatly as it could be but i think you
get the general idea this is
our circle
then they have a hyperbola x squared
minus y x squared over 9 minus y squared
of 4 is going to equal 1. this hyperbola
is going to open to the left and the
right since our x term is positive it's
going to look something like this you
can actually figure out the asymptotes
actually let me just do that let me
solve for y so you get
if you you would get let me write this
way negative y squared over four is
equal to negative x squared over nine
plus one i just subtracted x squared
over nine from both sides
and then we would get let's multiply
both sides by negative four you get y
squared is equal to 4
9 x squared minus 4 or y is equal to and
now this will just be the positive part
over here but i'm doing that so that we
can understand its asymptotes y
is equal to the square root of 4 over 9
x squared minus 4. so as x gets larger
and larger and larger this term right
here is going to stop it's going to stop
mattering so much and it's so as x
approaches infinity as x approaches
infinity this is going to approach the
square root of 4 over 9 x squared this
constant's not going to matter much and
so it's going to approach this thing
right over here is going to be 2 3 x so
it's going to if you imagine the slopes
let's see two-thirds if you go r if you
run three you rise to
so it's going to it's the asymptote is
going to look like that it's going to
approach that line over there
and it's going to be symmetric so it's
also going to approach so 3 and 2 it's
also going to approach that line over
there
and if we want to see where it
intersects the x-axis you just set x you
just said y is equal to 0 you get x
squared over 9 is equal to one so x is
going to be equal to plus or minus three
so the positive intersection is going to
be over there so our hyperbola on the
right side is going to look
something like something
something like that it's also going to
show up on the left side but that's less
interesting because it's not doing
anything with the circle now they told
us that the hyperbola and the circle
intersect at the points a and b
so this right here is the point a
this right here is the point b
in this question we want the equation of
the circle with a b as its diameter so a
b
with a b
with a b as the diameter i could have
drawn that a little bit straighter so
the equation of that circle right over
there so we essentially just need to
figure out where does this hyperbola
intersect this circle
now if we can the easiest way to do this
is to well we have two constraints here
let's solve for y squared for the circle
and then we can substitute that in for y
squared right here and see what x values
they intersect at and we want the x
value out here so something that looks
like this value is the one we want to
use and we can figure out the y value
the y value is going to be the radius of
our circle this the x value comma 0 will
be the center and then we'll have our
equation
so let's do that so this up here we have
let me let me do it in yellow so if we
subtract x squared and negative 8x from
both sides the equation of the circle
can be rewritten as
y squared is equal to i'm going to add
8x to both sides so it's 8x
and then subtract negative x squared
from or subtract x squared from both
sides at 8x minus x squared i really
just moved that and that over to the
right hand side of the equation now i
can take this and substitute for y
squared in the equation of the hyperbola
so the hyperbolas equation is x squared
over 9
minus
y squared over 4 is equal to 1. instead
of writing a y squared over there we
know that it has to satisfy this
equation as well so for y squared i'm
going to put an 8x
minus x squared and let's see if we can
solve let's see if we can solve this
right here this is just a straight up
quadratic equation although it might not
look like it just yet let's simplify
this so this tells us that x squared
x squared over nine
minus eight x over four so minus two x
plus x squared over four plus x squared
over four i just distributed essentially
the negative 1 4 over both these terms
is equal to
1.
let's see we can multiply the whole
thing times 36 to get rid of these
fractions because that's 4 times 9. so
36 divided by 9 is 4 so this is 4 x
squared minus 36 times 2 is 72
72 x plus 36 divided by 4 is 9 plus 9 x
squared is equal to 36
these two terms right here we can add
them we get 13
x squared
minus 72 x
and then we can subtract 36 from both
sides so minus 36 is equal to zero so
now we just have a straight up quadratic
equation we just have to find the x's
find the roots so let's use the
quadratic formula here
so x is going to be equal to negative b
so that's negative negative 72 so it's
72 plus or minus the square root of 72
squared i'll just write that 72 times 72
minus 4 times a
times c
c is negative 36. so that negative you
could put it out here and you just put
the 36
out back
and then all of that all of that over 2
times a so all of that over
all of that over
26. so the hard part is really to
simplify this but looks like something
we have some interesting stuff going on
so let me rewrite this part over here so
let me write over here 72
times 72 is the same thing
as this is the same thing as 2 times 36
times 2 times 36 right each of those are
that's the same thing as 72 times 72
and then we're adding to that 4 4 times
36 times 13. 4 times 36 times
13. and we're taking the square root of
this whole thing i'm just doing the work
out here so we don't so we don't waste
this real estate over here now we can
factor out a 4 we can factor out a 4
times 36 this is 4
and this is a 36 so this is equal to
i know it's getting let me write it a
little bit neater this is equal to
the square root
of we can take a 4 times 36 and actually
4 times 36 is 144. i'll just write 4
times 36 right here 4 times 36 now over
here we used the both twos and a 36 so
we have a 36 left we used this 4 times
36 so we have plus
13. so this becomes the square root of 4
times 4 times 36 is 144.
36 plus 13 is 49. so
it's great we're lucky that it actually
worked out to two perfect squares so
this is the square root of 144
times the square root of 49 which is 12
times 7 or this is equal to 84.
so this over here this business over
here simplifies to
72 plus or minus 84. this whole thing
over here simplified to 84
all of that over 26. now if we subtract
84 if we were to subtract 84 we would
get something over here that doesn't
make sense in this context we're looking
for something a positive x value so
let's only consider let's only consider
let's only consider the plus 84 and see
and see what we get so the first thing
to do actually let me just divide the
numerator and the denominator by 2. so
this is the same thing as 36
plus
42 over 13 and this is the same thing as
over 13
and it looks like 78 is divisible by 13.
78 divided by 13 is
6. this is equal to
6. so the x-coordinate here is 6. it's
right there so it's it's six we don't
know what the y coordinate is so let's
do that it's pretty easy to solve we
could substitute x equals six into any
of these equations this one is probably
easier right over here so we get y
squared is equal to 8 times 6 is 48
minus
48 minus 30 48 minus 36
which is equal to 12
and so y is equal to the square root of
12. we could simplify that radical if we
want but we know the point now it's 6
comma the square root sorry this point
over here is 6 comma 0 but the actual
intersect the center is 6 comma 0 but
the actual intersection point is going
to be
is going to be 6 comma
positive square root of 12 and i should
say this is a positive or negative
square root of 12 and this over here is
going to be 6
negative
square root of 12. this right here is 6
comma 0. that's the center of our circle
so what's the equation of this new
circle going to be what's the equation
of this new circle going to be
well we know its center its center is at
6 0
its center is at six here let me write
it down here its center is at six zero
so it's going to be x minus six squared
plus y minus zero squared is equal to
the radius squared now what's the radius
the radius is this height right over
here
or it's just equal to the y value at the
intersection it's the square root of 12.
now this is going to be the radius
squared the radius is squared of 12.
square root of 12 squared is 12. so the
equation is going to be x minus 6 and
let's see what form they have up here so
they actually multiply everything out so
let's just do that so this is going to
be x squared minus 12 x
plus 36 plus y squared
is equal to 12 and then we could
subtract 12 from both sides
and we get
x squared minus 12x
plus 24 plus y squared is equal to zero
and let's see which of the choices
let's see which of the choices match
that
let me copy it
and then let me paste it up here
let me paste it up here and it looks
like we have an x squared positive y
squared a
a
negative 12x and then a positive 24
negative 12x positive 24. so it looks
like
our answer is a did i do that right x
squared plus y squared
minus 12x plus 24. yup our answer is a